c'est une étape obligatoire dont le
parcours de citoyenneté la jdc journée
défense et citoyenneté concernent chaque
année 800 mille jeunes en france
objectif détecter des situations de
décrochage mais aussi expliquer les
enjeux de la défense
pour cette session à la caserne d'artois
à versailles trois femmes engagées sont
venus témoigner de leur parcours
il faut donner le meilleur de soi voilà
oui effectivement il faut il faut
essayer de faire peut-être un peu plus
mais bon moi j'ai toujours trouvé ça on
va dire plus un challenge motivant devra
essayer de toujours viser le haut on
soit un homme ou une femme on a les
mêmes difficultés et les mêmes facilités
dans le métier c'est pas parce qu'on est
une femme qu'on peut pas atteindre ce
genre de carrière et avoir sa place dans
ce type de métier durant une vingtaine
de minutes ces femmes ingénieures
sapeurs pompiers aux juristes ont
échangé avec les citoyens de demain
le but montrer qu'il existe de
nombreuses opportunités de carrière dans
ce secteur le taux de féminisation varie
en fonction des armées le service de
santé peut s'enorgueillir d'accueillir
67 % de personnel féminin le service de
commissariat des armées
lui est à 30% l'armée de terre par
exemple compte 10% 10 à 12 % de
personnel féminin parmi ses rangs mais
il faut savoir que toutes les armes et
toutes les armées n'était pas ouverte au
personnel féminin les femmes ont tout
autant le droit de représenter la france
de se battre pour notre pays et j'en
suis fier je suis fier que petit à petit
ça avance
en 2012 le ministère des armées a nommé
un haut fonctionnaire à l'égalité des
droits pour valoriser le personnel
féminin